Nói chừng có mấy mọi người có khóa xin cần về trường mình in gì để vang họ mời trọng đặt tình tốt
Kết quả tốt sẽ thế phía đồ này này chứ sẽ chụi quả luôn nhá
Đầu tiên nó xin là các bạn học xin lớp mời mới lớp mời mù tạm bia là khoảng xin lớp mời
Ná các tất bình của các bạn hát đầu với các bạn sẻ
Thế một sự vô cùng mơ nữ ở trong khoảng xin dụng các học tập cho được xin bình lý các bạn
Thì với lớp mời mới lớp mời mời mời mù tạm bạn ím nhất các bạn chuẩn bị tất cả thầy được nít tử sau
Đầu tiên nó là mẹ mù tạm lúc xin học tập
Nó xin học lại là một cái hả hứa nó trọng các bạn hả nó học
Chúng tôi biết rằng là chúng ta sẽ học đến đâu và học đến đâu cho nó hiểu hả
Nói chừng nào khi không ngồi lâu xin học thì có học dự hơi rất là nhiều người thay của xin lớp
Đặc biệt là nhiều chiến lớp học dậy đến đâu và học đến đây
Cả tế thu kiế tuổi người rất là tụi đọc
Nói chừng thì và phần ngon học nếu đi các bạn không muốn được điểm các bạn vụ của bạn
Còn tử lộ xin học cho bạn tâm mình ở xa
Tống thường nếu đi các bạn mà phần ngôn lộ xin học thì các bạn kê đang ý nhất các bạn học
Nếu kêu khoảng tế thay này trực hả?
ở xa, các bạn kể tổng khoảng tử lập mời lớn mời mù tỉnh lắm mẹ hai
thì hơi lộ xây dựa chết, lộ xây dựa chết, lộ xin học của tụi tế tế thôi
và tập chỉ là các bạn này nó học và xuất bắt sớm ngay trong hẹ này thôi
Nha, có một điều quan trọng nếu mà khoảng xin lớn mời lớn mù tụi cân về trình mi
và là on tập là nhé kính thức của nếu mà học trước
Nha, báo xin lớn mời mù tụi cân xà của chúng vấn lý mời và hùng và công tức và lý thích trọng tâm
Nha, bởi nhé báo xin lớn mời tân mình của các bạn
thì có ngon xanh lại một chút nước kích thích về khoảng những nhìn
trong trường xin lớp chiến và nhá, Nha, Nha, Bởi vì lễ như báo xa và khoảng hổ thịt
cân phải ô tập lại để cho các bạn thấy học tốt cho trường xin cơp báo xa tới
và đặc biệt là các bạn học xin lớn mời hai, nhưng mà học xin 2 cái chiến năm nay
thì tập két trắng là khoảng với đối mặt với một lòng kỳ tí bỏ sự biến đột lớn nhất rồi
và trọng khoảng lăn bởi vì hẹn như bỏ lục của mà trọng xảy rất nhiều người dưới
và trọng hình thức tí trong cơ chế tí và trắng là các bạn sẽ là người nọn nâu trong những năm học trước tới
bởi vì vậy, chỉ là 2 cái chiến trường mình đúng thấy 3 yên túng sau
đồ đến mô, nó chỉ là một lộ xin học tập, và sẽ tìm của mình đó là lộ xin học, để đúng chỗ quạc
bây giờ là khoảng những học đến đâu, và học mang rồi đi sau và sẽ phần này và học thì thế nào
để bắt trước các lộ xin thì hãy tăng ký khoảng của thay, để xa
điều số 2 là khoảng hệ trường thì mình mình hành trang tất tốt
ở nhà về kiếm tất tự, bên ngoài, để chúng ta trọng lửa những ngày học mà chúng ta mong muốn
ở sau mà rất sát tuyền mà cái địa học, và tự nhiên ngày người rất sát tự nhiên
và có thể có lực tự mục tiêu cho bạn thân mình trong tương mô học, chúng tôi không có ý thí của bạn
để xa cái điều này là nhiều dịch quan trọng, chúng ta mắt đầu với nghĩ đến, nên ngày người mà chúng ta sẽ học
và chúng ta sẽ sắp tới chúng ta học sau khi mà chúng ta tốt nghiệp sau khi phí trọng của tôi ra
và một điều cuối cùng là việc quan trọng cho hẹn gà chỉ nói ra thay nổi, tâm thay mà sắp sách
và phung để ra lý khó sẽ trở hiệu quà, ở vì khi các bạn lấy lớn mấy hai là các bạn sẽ phải học với mối cửng
và tập cao hơn rất nhiều, sở là học sinh lớn mối lớn mấy nổi mà chúng ta phung chỉ học, khi cái món nó chỉ chương trở chương lửb,
mà chúng ta còn học, thì cái món chẳng đông để chúng ta có thể ý thí để học, trả nhà tòa liên hoa này
các bạn phải xem thế gián như học thêm, đưa học, binh hoài, bủ trở binh hoài, hợp và ký học với thay, có bao lấy khóc của thay cũng choo bà
rất là giày, thì nhanh việc chúng ta bắt buộc phay, tên đối thời gian tâm lối lấy khóc thì làm sao không lấy khóc thì mình chuồng nhau này
thì cũng là cái điều đó là quan trọng mà các bạn không xin lớn mấy hai là mình phải chuẩn bị các bạn
và tên như mối sử trình bị không hơn là thứ thái cả tháng tà mài, thì rất nhiều học sinh là chuẩn bị và đầu lên trường mình lớn và đầu học
để chuẩn bị học thật của các bạn, các bạn cũng có một những tiêu nửa thật là vui phay, tên nhiều điểm cao, đầy hứng khởi cho một năm hỏng mới sắp tới quá nhé